we went out to this horse racing thing
and something really dangerous and weird
and bad had happened to someone and we
drove home and I called my mum and dad
and I was like you won't believe what
happened we're coming home blah blah
blah I just felt so much comfort knowing
that Mum and Dad were there and that's
at the age of 25 and I was like mum and
dad are there thank God like they're
there I'm coming home they're both there
and we can like talk about it and they
say don't worry later you did the right
thing I'm like you sure I did the right
thing yes you did the right thing you
know and that just like fills you with
so much like comfort and stability and
even now like I can call my dad he'll
answer the phone and he'll talk to me
for like an hour about any problem that
I have and my mum like you need that
that is so important